you
everyone is Jerry Amman leeches or guy
just had a seek out for a free check
game this is one of my favorite variants
for chess if you're not familiar with it
it's just like regular chess but with
the additional rule if you're the first
person to deliver a third check and it
doesn't have to be consecutive that's
another way you can win so checks are
very important like if I play Knight
here allowing Knight takes is not a good
idea
so a knight here white basically has to
take back gonna play here so this is a
5-2 again just for fun as usual I won't
be doing any analysis after this so hmm
I'm right now considering night here not
sure I could go there maybe one move
later I think I'm I like this a6 move
Knight here Knight here although let's
say Knight d4 I pretty much have to take
otherwise I get one check in 94 Knight
takes pawn takes Knight B for Queen here
but then II 5 and then the knight could
play here and that's certainly worth the
investment to give up a pond to deliver
a check I'm gonna I'm going to stop
knight to b5 so it's like something that
you would send see you not just a
regular game this kind of formation you
six a six c5 just wondering I really
want to play here you know what I
probably should get some more pieces out
and in fact I think this can be a quite
good idea fishing-pole ideas with Knight
g4 and then pawn push because then
that's going to bring my rook to life
possibilities for giving a check on each
one and maybe the Queen coming out in
fact I want to go forward with it right
now
so let's see how this turns out I
haven't played this guy before or girl I
don't know I haven't played this person
before they have about good minute
advantage on me so this is always
something that's quite scary in fact
they might go for this right now
95 I don't have to take if I take I
think it's just a loss by force
take pawn takes discover check another
check by the rook and then Queen coming
out to deliver a final check the Knights
are the Knights tend to be worth well I
think we can say for sure the Knights
are more valuable in three check than
the bishops they could really do a good
job if they if you only need one check
remaining and it's tough to avoid that
there's no blocking a knight so hmm
Queen e2 is this setting up knight here
I might want to play Bishop here hmm so
maybe maybe this first yeah let me let
me the link that night there he's not
going anywhere
h3 is no bother just gonna keep him
right there hmm maybe this next this
Knight up removes my queen will be
really quick to come out to h4 I'm quite
underdeveloped only two pieces out
opponents already castled but I don't
know how poorly placed my king is on e8
this is certainly something I have to be
aware of late d5 whew now that's
interesting
well how about I take Knight takes pawn
Knight takes pawn takes this Knight has
to move and then and then maybe Bishop
d6 pawn takes first
I takes our pond takes I'm gonna go with
hmm let's see Knight takes pawn I think
this is what they're setting up also
this Bishop could come out soon let me
take with the pun I think that's more
forceful I 95 of thinking Bishop here I
think I'm losing I think I am going to
lose this let's see mmm okay I think I
need to get into position to at least
give a check ouch this is big trouble
this is very big trouble Bishop here
yeah I think they could do like some
pawn push and if I take eventually like
a double sac on this e 6 square might be
an idea there's two pieces trained on
this e-file opposite my King so minute
edge this is the only game I'm going to
play so let's make the best of it Bishop
g5 is quite annoying on f6 there might
be a sacrifice this is the one that
scares me the most here and they can
already deliver one check this knight
same colors my king same color square f6
c7 so there's one check that White has
to be very very careful it doesn't that
open up hmm let's see I'm not sure what
else this is the one I mean why not here
right developing a piece throwing a
punch of my queen what I really play f6
hmm where else is there and after block
do I come out like this or maybe I could
start to consider Bishop takes pawn ah
I'm Bishop g5 I could have played Bishop
takes h2 okay I'm very tempted to play
h5 and they probably should do that
let's let's open up the H file
and I will be sacking my rocket pawn
takes or Knight takes that can't be
right if they take on this square also
with the bishop coming in here on Bishop
g5 I could maybe even consider pawn
takes first pawn takes Bishop takes
Queen so you have this variation
I really have to calculate it through to
its end now pawn takes and the time to
do at pawn takes Bishop takes Queen pawn
takes pawn check that must be good I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot for it
let's see if they take my queen you know
I can also consider just taking once and
then recapturing the bishop mm-hmm let's
see if they take it the moment of truth
do they have the time to calculate it
probably but it's getting down to the
wire here listen to even on time Bishop
takes Queen which pawn would I take
probably this one I don't want to allow
white to hide behind my pawn if I take
like this ooh they did take my queen
okay let's take like this that's check
if the King goes to one of these two I
could deliver another one so it logs it
over here I've delivered one check team
black one check in and now how do they
avoid two more checks if the knight goes
here or if the King goes here I could
take on this square ooh so they're
giving the Queen back I can give this
second check wow this must be winning
you see Bishop takes h2 if the King
moves anywhere to these two I could
deliver a third check so you have to
take my [ __ ] hub Bishop takes pawn a
second check and then this must be right
I'm gonna I'm gonna take and give that
second check they haven't given any
checks to me yeah so how are they going
to recapture Queen or night
a Knight takes Knight I'm going to take
the Queen taking the Queen on the next
move no matter what I'm pretty sure so
let's see a minute a minute - okay I
only need one more check could I do this
Knight here no you could take my rook
would check how ridiculous is that okay
you just take here and I'm threatening
check they can only give two checks
tonight here take the bishop another
check here two checks each and then
that's it I'm threatening Knight takes
Knight and that's game over and yeah
when that happens I also have Knight e5
threatening a final check here about 30
seconds each okay that can't be right
I'm taking this Knight and then I'm back
in checking range yeah I don't think
there was a good solution at that stage
King takes Knight okay now this is
actually just gonna be game over they
resigned right there okay um yeah
interesting variant for sure this is
actually one of my favorite variants in
chess I wanted to share this with you
guys here on the channel it's the first
video I'm posting like this to the
YouTube channel here but yeah feel free
to I'll give any feedback let me know if
your if you played three check yourself
and
and what sort of strategies do you think
are good for this variant of chess okay
so as usual feel free to leave any
comments in the comment section below
and I'll catch you in the next video
take care bye